I will never get over the moral superiority of people
who are actively forcing children to give birth
and perform reproductive labor
for their abusers and for the government
these people who are not troubled by the fact that women across the country
are describing themselves as walking coffins
because their government
will not allow them to terminate their non viable pregnancy
why doesn't the government force everybody to give their organs
for all of the children who die waiting on the organ donor list every year
why don't we force everybody who can
to give blood at their annual preventative checkups
why don't we do those things
you can't even take organs from a dead person
these are real people with complicated pregnancies
with complicated lives with dreams
with facts that you don't know
this moral superiority of sitting on your couch
and getting on your keyboard and shaming people
meanwhile
you are inflicting serious harm on millions of women throughout the country
yeah the times we are living in are utterly barbaric
I completely agree with you on that